all right hello everybody my name is
Alejandro Ramirez I am a grandmaster
living in Dallas I've been a grandmaster
for about ten years
um this is I believe the advanced
beginners class so we will be covering a
little bit about material balance and
the importance of sacrificing for time
and when you can't do this there's going
to be two sides of the coin in this in
this lecture feel free to interrupt me
at any time just raise your hand if you
have any questions or if you wish to
answer something now the first game that
I'm going to go over what with you guys
is a very very famous game a very very
old game you guys know who Paul Morpheus
Paul Moore so it's a pretty unanimous
yes
anybody know don't be ashamed Paul
Morphy was probably one of the first
chess geniuses to have ever played the
game he left a long time ago in the
1850s and he produced some of the first
chess masterpieces and he was very
influential in chess because he
understood that the power of the pieces
didn't always necessarily mean that one
side had more pieces than the other he
understood that the activity of the
pieces sometimes triumphed over anything
else on the board so we're going to look
at a game that was played about a
hundred and sixty years ago and then
contrasted to one that I played just
about last week and see how much chess
has evolved in the mean time so this is
known as the opera game because it was
played in a during an opera or at least
that's what the myth goes Paul Morphy is
playing two opponents and apparently was
a little bit of a distracting
environment but it was one of the
classic games of all time now I'm not
sure if you guys know this but not all
of the games of all time survive the way
that we know some of the games is that
if the opponents thought it was worthy
enough they would save the game but
unfortunately most
the games that Paul Morphy played and
many grandmasters played in the 1850
we're completely lost
they were just never saved opponents
thought that it was just not a worthy
game and they wouldn't like either trash
it or never reproduce it for the general
public luckily this was preserved and
has been reproduced many times and is
for us to enjoy and to learn from it so
you guys probably already know some of
the basic ideas to chests in the in the
opening you know you develop your pieces
you control the center you attack pawns
you don't you don't blunder anything you
know move your pieces three times during
the opening so everybody should be
familiar with this concept right but
what do you do to punish those that for
some reason decide not to follow the
rules this is exactly what Paul Morphy
does in this in this game so he's white
and he plays efore which is you know the
most common opening back then a little
bit of history
efore was considered to be the only good
move up until like the 1910 in the 1910
Lasker had the idea that d4 was also
playable and actually from then on d4
was a little bit more common nowadays
there's a 50/50 split between efore and
d4 among grandmasters although you still
will see the English opening and Knight
of three and other random moves once in
a while so his opponent place be five
equals nine of three and now the most
common response here in this position is
knight c6 simply defending the pawn with
a natural knight move which would be
this however this is not what there is a
point in bit like d6 does anybody know
what this opening is called it
the filler or defense this is named
after Philidor who lived not too far
away from from morphe and in the time
era this is actually really annoying I
need to change this
how do we get rid of this arrows
you go okay that's good
all right no more arrows that's awesome
okay so black defends the center in a
very natural way he's protecting it with
the bonds very solid but at the same
time it's a little bit passive what do
you think is relatively wrong with this
move anybody
yes both answers seem pretty correct to
me has the black Bishop on f8 this one
right here is unfortunately kind of
blocked in however this is not exactly a
terrible thing the bishop could go to e7
and some people still play this nowadays
to take advantage of this it's very
common for white to strike at the center
with d4
notice how white in this position will
try to gain space in the center while
black will try to sustain the center if
black were to in this position take this
phone right here and white would we take
with either the queen or the night
notice that white immediately gets
what's called the space advantage he's
able to control the board pretty much up
to the fourth rank well black is really
only playing with three ranks the fifth
rank being contested by both sides for
this reason it's a little bit of
unpleasant to play this with black a lot
of grandmasters don't like to take on d4
nowadays there are two common
continuations for black one is 9 f6 this
Knight comes to f6 to counter-attack
this pawn on e4 and the other one is to
play 97 and similarly defend this pawn
on e5 however we're not talking about a
modern game here it's not like there was
a bunch of chess books published and
it's not like they could go to the
advanced beginner class and be taught
openings back then there was no idea on
how exactly you should play chess in the
beginning moves so I mean filler hadn't
even invented the filler to fill their
defense when this was played so they
played Bishop g4 the apone
so morphe which seems like a very
logical move right in essence they are
defending the 5 pawn indirectly how are
they doing this they're pending the
opinion the knight to the Queen right
however there's a slight flaw with the
idea if I take the pawn on e5 and they
recapture suddenly White has a tactical
resource to get out of the pin
Queen takes Queen check the king is
forced to recapture and after Knight
takes e5 white is up upon everybody
follow this yeah nope no questions just
making sure okay so a pawn takes pawn
takes Queen takes King takes ninety five
whites of a point so this is not their
idea they take only five and now you
cannot recapture any 5s black they take
the time to take on f3 which is fine
after Bishop takes f3 Queen takes f3
pawn takes d5 the fun on e5 is no longer
attacked however this is not entirely
equal for black in essence what has an
extra development move well which move
does he have on top of black I mean the
position is symmetrical bit pretty much
the Queen is out right now this is a
very very slight advantage very very
slight advantage but we'll see how more
if he takes this very slight advantage
and converts it into an initiative and
this initiative turns out winning the
game the first thing about the
initiative and this has been known since
pretty much the late 1800s is that you
have to keep the attack going if you
have the initiative and you don't keep
the attack going and you exhaust your
resources for one reason or another
then you will no longer have the
initiative and therefore you will no
longer have the advantage that is why
from now on if Paul if more if you can
threaten something
and at the same time improve his
position he will do so for that reason
the most logical move in this position
is Bishop c4 he's threatening as
scholars made on f7 so it's not only
just that he developed a beast but he
developed it in a very natural way now
compare this to a normal scholars may
where you just put the Queen on f3 the
Queen is unnatural there but in this
variation the Queen has already come to
f3 in a very natural sequence of moves
therefore now the bishop and the Queen
can attack f7 without punishment now
black has to defend this somehow right
that's how chess works somebody thrown
this Jack made you better defend against
it he has a couple of choices what seems
like the most natural so there's a
couple of options right the first is to
move the Queen either to e7 or t7
defending f7 or to develop the knight in
essence blocking the Queen from the f7
squared both are actually probably good
choices but following the more logical
steps of chess Knight f6 is probably the
better idea because you get to develop
all your pieces this is however a slight
mistake even though it is more natural
it is a slight mistake because it lets
morphe create a double attack in this
position the rules in chess are meant to
be Brooke kind of like rules in life in
this position it will be very natural to
develop piece you could develop 9c3
you could put the bishop on g5 you could
castle and they're all fine moves
they're all good moves
but sometimes sometimes you just have to
take advantage of the opportunities your
opponent gives you Bishop takes pawn is
possible and after King takes bishop
will be your idea so Queen b3 so this is
the suggestion Bishop takes f7 check the
King must take and then Queen b3 forks
receive everywhere lose the king and the
pawn right however after the king moves
and I regain the pawn
I have only gained two pawns for the
bishop the rook is trapped yes but when
the knight moves to d7 the Queen will be
defending the rook so that's not an
issue in essence I have only recuperated
two pawns for a bishop so I'm still at a
disadvantage now it's good that you see
this kind of ideas but there might be
another way to implement them in this
position Queen b3 first has the same
idea without giving up the bishop and
now black is in some serious trouble
there is the farn f7 being targeted and
there is the Queen hitting p7 obviously
the power on f7 is more important
because it's the one that's keeping the
King alive
so more free place sorry the opponents
play 27 now Quinta xb7 is perfectly
possible and I assure you that any
Grandmaster nowadays would have played
Queen takes p7 however the idea of black
was to play Queen before check screen
comes here Chuck in essence trading the
Queen's and diminishing the initiative
but would be left down upon but not in a
hopeless position more fee once more and
this is very common of the romantic era
of chess in which material was
definitely secondary to initiative and
time and development what he plays is
fine but maybe not the best move Knight
c3 it is however very logical he
develops the night going to d5 going to
d5 the threat of b7 remains and it is
relatively uncomfortable to defend b7
black must spend another move not
developing if he wants to keep the pawn
in this position he plays c6 opening the
Queen up to the b7 pawn but he's still
not developing
or if it keeps up the pressure develops
on g5 the problem was a queen before
here I guess is the question is that
right now the Queen has left an
important post see the Queen was moved
to e7 for a reason right to defend the
pawn on f7 right now after Bishop takes
f7 check there is yeah there's really no
way that black can successfully deal
with this maybe he will survive for a
few more moves but the loss of the pawn
and the position of the weakened King
seems like it will be a very big deal so
unfortunately no black couldn't have
done that neither last move nor this
move right now he's still a little bit
stuck defending his position actually
his position is very uncomfortable here
there is a lot of threats going on the
main thread being Bishop takes f6 trying
to distract the Queen
the idea is to force the Queen to take
on f6 after which remember that we have
this pressure on b7 for this reason more
if his opponents decide to play b5 which
seems like a relatively logical move
they defend the pawn by putting it on
the influence of the c6 pawn and they
hit the bishop which is very dangerous
that Bishop is a trademark of of White's
pressure it's the one that's hitting f7
it's the one that's coordinating with
the Queen to threaten the king that's
why they decide to basically get rid of
it now what is the what are some logical
moves her white yes
no 935 was actually what was played but
what are some see first more natural
plays yeah
remove the bishop right in essence if I
take on v5 I will be losing material so
I have to justify this somehow and here
I want to I want you guys to remember
this position and I want you guys to
understand when sacrificing material is
good and when sacrificing material is
bad
in this position Knight takes d5 is
correct nine takes b5 almost guarantees
a win but why does it work why does it
work it is a check but just because
there's a check on the board doesn't
mean that it's lethal the reason that in
this position the check works is because
black is down in development this idea
that black is behind in development that
he hasn't put his pieces to active
squares means that he hasn't been able
to safeguard his King imagine for a
moment that the King has Castle and
switched the king with the rook Kings on
g8 or a trade and the rooks on e8 pretty
normal after castling position then
there is no reason for white to go ahead
and sacrifice on b5 there's simply no
reason but because that King has been
left up in the open because it has been
left in the center because the sacrifice
opens lines towards the King then the
sacrifice has the potential of working
and upon further study the sacrifice
just wins however what follows is not
only an example of initiative winning
against material it's also one of the
prettiest combinations that chess has
seen in history Knight takes is correct
pawn takes b5 and then Bishop takes d5
check however you do realize that black
is not entirely
that yet you check but they can cover
night covers on d7 of course this night
why didn't I not play the other night so
as to not hang your queen it's pinned
white castles and the idea of castling
is double fold it develops the rook on a
one but which other rook did it develop
and why was it developed there's only
one other rook the one on h1 but why did
castle develop the Rope free of the trap
you released exactly in this position
there was a rook on a1 which was not
doing anything right let's look at the
position
Brooklyn a one's not doing anything so
once you swing it over to d1 it's
immediately doing what it's supposed to
do it's hitting d7 it's on the open file
wonderful but there's a big difference
between playing the rook to d1 and
castling when I play the rook to d1 I
still leave this rook without any way of
getting back in the game it would still
take me a couple of Tempe to Castle and
bring the rook over to where it belongs
so castling in essence not only develops
the a1 rook it also helps me develop the
h1 rook there is a thread on the board
the rook on d1 added pressure to a very
sensitive spot right so what is black's
pretty much only move in this position
yeah rook d8 is the only move because
you have to defend the night there are
options for white in this position but
the correct move in this position is to
develop with Tempe remember the maximum
that was actually said by William Stein
it's
when you have the initiative you must
attack if you don't attack then your
advantage slips and fades if your
advantage fades from your ab material
rook takes Knight is correct this helps
me develop the rook on h1 bring it over
to d1 and continue the attacking process
there's only one choice for black right
the Knights pinned the Queen cannot
recapture without losing the Queen
therefore rook takes d7 is absolutely
forced the rook is pinned and I take
advantage of this by playing rook to d1
now seeing that there is no other way of
protecting the rook on d1 black tries to
at least relieve the pressure by trading
Queens
Queenie six is played with the idea of
trying to trade now what could take on
e6 pawn 20 c6 Bishop takes f6 pawn takes
f6 and then at the end the rook is
hanging and I recovered my rook right
I want a rook but how much am i down
right now right so I'm down r4 okay fine
McDonough rook and I gain a row I'm even
sure I will be up a couple of bonds
which should be enough to win but it
feels like your initiative in this
position should give you more than that
there's a little bit about intuition a
lot of time grandmasters have this
intuition that there should be something
more something work concrete and in this
position what actually has a winning
combination
go on a little bit louder so everybody
can hear right and this is what happened
in the morphine
after Bishop takes d7 again black cannot
recapture on this end with the Queen
right you're down you're pretty much
done the Queen they took with the night
but after queen bee a check which is a
fabulous distraction sacrifice Knight
takes be a drug da track mate why
disable to checkmate with only two
pieces the two pieces remaining but this
two pieces are more valuable than the
entire army that black does have yes
pieces are not developed there exactly
the king is trapped pretty much with the
open he was never moved into a safe
position what was consistently attacking
so it's very natural that at some point
the attack crashes through in this
position the bishop on g5 in the rukon
da I saw the white needed to create a
very common mating pattern well common
for us not coming back then and the game
was over now
I want to point out that this was a
knight an 1850 game okay so I don't
think anybody was around back then chess
has evolved justice-involved greatly
it's very easy to get seduced by this
kind of game some try to sacrifice as
many pieces as you can try to open those
lines but nowadays chess is played a
little bit differently
chess is played with a little bit more
subtlety chess display with a little bit
more of a positional character because
nowadays grandmasters and strong players
and you will know this concerts just
more games you play know how to defend
better they know that they can't leave
the King out there so long they know
their openings better they're not going
to allow you this initiative that
I had with the king and with the Queen
and the bishop and now I'm going to show
you a game that I played just last week
against another Grandmaster I am white
and I am playing Grandmaster Eugene
pearl Stein who I believe lives in
California he is one of the top
grandmasters in America it's been
playing for many years and in this game
we're going to see a completely
different setup we're going to see a
setup in which I have developed properly
I get my opponent tries to crash through
with the sacrifice and we will see why
this either works or doesn't work yeah
why would you go to the strategy with
you know you were very strong we'll get
to that when we get to the position but
it's an excellent question so first of
all we will change the opening
completely efore was very common in
1850s probably the only move nowadays I
said the d44 about 50/50 but sometimes
sometimes the English opening appears
once in a while and this was the last
round game I really really needed to win
my opponent is what's called like when I
was one of those players that just
studies all day he knows how the theory
so I didn't really want to get into a
big book battle the English is a it's a
nice opening it's not the most sharp
attempt by white to gain an advantage
it's relatively positional it gives
black lots of options but it's fully
playable my opponent answers with c5
known as the symmetrical English I can
assume the guys guess why it's called a
symmetrical English but it doesn't stay
symmetrical for too long there is
actually a very nifty difference created
by this pawn push to e6 now I do want to
that Knight f6 to remain with that
symmetry is fully playable but the
symmetry will not last forever the extra
tempo by white will give him an upper
hand in the center this is not too
important to the lesson is just like a
general knowledge kind of fact e 6 is
done to kind of create an imbalance in
the game here black is going to play 9
g7 and attempt to take the center with
d5 I have no reason to be afraid of this
right away so I simply develop and
notice how both sides in this position
develop as quickly as they can they
don't waste too many times on random
pawn moves unless they're directed
towards the center they don't waste any
moves that are on the flanks until their
position is developed I've already
cancelled on my opponent will Castle
relatively soon it's a very different
setup it's a very solid very intuitive
setup I develop my knight he develops
his I push my phone he castles and I
play a little bit of a subtle move
Bishop g5 the idea of Bishop g5 is that
he might want to play d5 in the near
future and I'm pinning the knight that's
reinforcing that Center and after h6 I
have a couple of choices now if you were
widen you just play Bishop g5 and you
got your Bishop spooked like this you
what would you do
remove it to d2 or you could take on e7
right the problem is the nowadays the
pair of bishops is considered to be a
significant advantage the pair of
bishops is that advantage in which you
have two bishops and your opponent has a
combination of either a knight and a
bishop or two knights facing them it's
considered to be really good because if
the position eventually opens up the
bishops will be worth more than the
night on the bishop or the night in the
night it's just the way the chess works
since some positions do lock up and the
Knights are eventually worth more
trading a bishop for the night right out
of the opening is not a terrible thing
however it does limit your chances
eventually many games after the bishops
have been traded do tend to open up and
then you wish you had that bishop back
in this position I play Bishop d2 and
we'll see you in the following in the
following sequence why I encouraged my
opponent to play this move h6 it seems
like I give him a free temple but I
actually have my ideas
he plays d5 I take I take and I play a
three now the idea of a three is that
okay I've developed all my pieces I have
to do something now part of chess
nowadays you developed all your pieces
and you must have a strategy afterwards
the normal strategy in this position for
white is to go in the Queen side once I
play three I'll follow up with rugby one
and break the Queen side with b4 this
will lead to probably an isolated pawn
or some kind of weakness on that side
which I can take advantage of
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah not that
relevant a3 is just very normal way of
playing the position he develops because
that's what grandmasters do they develop
I play rugby one with the idea of before
and he goes rook c8 and now now already
out of theory I start wondering what his
idea of rook c8 is the first thing is
yeah
yeah if he goes to c8 but if that
creates a weakness in the seventh file
he does create a little bit of a
weakness on p7 but he has a plan he
actually comes in with a plan and @n and
when I look at this position this is
kind of my thought process the guy goes
rook c8 and he knows that I want to play
before because it's like i telegraphed
it to him i buttered a huge billboard i
played a 300 b1 it's not like i'm kind
of hiding my intention i want to play b4
and play on the queenside
so it goes rook c8 it kind of
discouraged just a little bit because he
has a rook on what would be an open file
but not enough towards the point where I
wouldn't play it there is nothing that
he can actually do with the open file so
I can still play before and then I think
what else would the rook be doing on see
it and then I realize after before maybe
he doesn't want to open up the position
and the Queen side rather he wants to
close it how could he do this
she's yes anybody
he could play d4 which would be one way
but that would kind of encourage my
break on b4 because after d4 the base of
the pawn structure becomes c5 and let's
remember names of its old idea of how to
deal with pawn structures you hit at the
base right basically my entire idea is
to hit on c5 which becomes the base of
the structure b6 is an idea but then it
doesn't make sense why did he play the
rock on c8 he could have just left it on
a he could've played b6 immediately at
this point and that's exactly what he
wanted to do after before he wanted to
play c4 kind of like passing the pawn
and creating that close structure on the
queenside
so from now on and to answer your
question why did he go for this I
realized that my opponent wants to close
the Queen said and I immediately start
calculating things I start creating
ideas there are some good and bad things
about closing the pawn center so let's
analyze the position in our heads after
b4 b4 c4 and let's assume I swap pawns D
takes c4 d takes c4 everybody picture
that what are some of the good things
that happen on black sand and what are
some of the bad things that happen on
his hunt what's an obvious good thing
that happened
be
who has a nap was very far black might
have an ass before
efore you said you sure it's not d4e for
alrighty for ya in essence I I got he
got rid of the pony for but
unfortunately has no pieces around it
right so yeah II for is weakened but he
has no way of exploiting this what what
else what good things happen to this
position was be for you go see for so we
got the first idea there is this very
weakened b3 position right that is
protected by this pawn on c4 if you can
get a knight there that's awesome that's
a pretty powerful Knight however he
can't go through a five why not
well I see it remember that we're
looking at the position b4 c4 pawn takes
pawn takes why can he go through a five
there will be a pawn on before covering
that square however he does have a route
toward towards b3 through d4 and we'll
see that he actually accomplishes this
during the game however one of the
terrible things that happens to black is
that he has the right has a blockade and
we're going to understand this concept
of a blockade I did play before because
I thought this was good for me
c4 takes takes and now black has a
passed pawn does anybody know the
definition of a passed ball which melon
or clone can shake on its way to
queening right upon which no other part
can take on its way to Queenie or block
it exact or bakit yes important
so in essence e4 right now is a passed
pawn this is the same laughable that the
pawn is passed right now it is right
because it's so blockaded that it's not
going to go anywhere but it's this
little resources that grandmasters
sometimes see in this position is that
not they know that eventually there is
this kinetic possibility that this one
will be dangerous in any ending this
phone will be dangerous if I swap the c3
Knight this phone will be dangerous for
now however it is still the middle game
and I can exploit the fact that this
point is relatively out of play normally
we think of pieces as being out of play
if a knight is on the rim it's dim as
does English saying goes and it's out of
play therefore it's not as influential
but pawn software of this - sometimes
when pawns are badly placed they're not
as influential as they should be and
therefore that let's now let's in pieces
into squares that they shouldn't be
letting them into think of pawns as
barriers for your opponent's pieces to
get into
there was a very important function that
this pawn in the center was creating and
that was to allow the file the D file to
remain closed and we'll see why this is
important my first move was queen c1
quincy one has two ideas the first one
is to move the rook to d1 and occupy
that very very very important file it's
the only open file in the game this will
leap to him having to move the Queen in
a very awkward position notice that his
queen doesn't have any good moves he
doesn't want to move the Queen it's fine
on da but I'm going to force him what is
the second idea behind queen c1 taking
on aged six right h6 is hanging it's not
defended so Black has two ways of
defending this King on h7 and now he
could push the pawn on g5 or an h5 those
do defend the pawn but they are very
awkward right I mean you're pushing the
pawns in front of the King you're
exposing yourself to sacrifice is not
not the best
so besides King h7 what other way of the
night at five excellent so as
grandmasters we have to analyze this
position and be like which one should
you play which one's more natural not
easy right the King on h7 is more
natural as a defensive move but the
negative five is more natural as an
offensive move then another five also
wants to go to d4 and b3 which is where
it wants to go right however the King on
each zone is safer there was a serious
drawback with King h7 the problem for
him is that after rook t1 I am still
threatening this here because of this
here
the Queen doesn't have any good squares
if it goes to c7 I'll chase it away with
either Bishop f4 or with 95 he goes to
Queen b6
I'll go 9a 4 and still chase it away
there's no good way of blocking the D
file and Bishop h6 is a serious threat
therefore my opponent plays Knight f5 so
that after rook d1 he goes Queen e7 yes
and here's where grandmasters are a
little bit more clever than they used to
be efore is actually not a good move at
all in this position the problem with E
4 is that after and I saw this when I
played b4 and Queen c1 and all this
thing I have to see it before I went
into this variation is that after night
D fourth of course he has to protect the
night I swapped Knights and he I take on
h6 he has this intermediate movement 93
so he's attacking my Queen right which I
have to move away from I cannot take the
knight because I would just be down the
exchange so where do I move my Queen can
move it to f4 why not why can't I move
it to f4 first of all
you could go to e3 the problem with
Queen to f4 is the design is hanging
right
there's nobody defending the night so 23
and he has this very very very annoying
idea that after he swaps bishops he goes
Queen d2 and honestly during the game
was very annoyed at this because now he
has two threats he's attacking my queen
and he's attacking my knight right is
there any good way of defending yeah you
could trade Queens but then after he
recaptures with the knight what happens
he forced her he forced the rooks
since a relatively pretty combination
that he saw all the way back when he
played out at five so to avoid all this
oh the problem with f4 is that the night
is still hanging on c3 I would work
though for is a good idea and it's after
still not so clear after f4 takes push
the pawn black still has to do some work
but he should be winning instead of that
I first played this intermediate and
very exact move roopd one like in the
other situation he's being threatened
with Bishop takes h6
therefore he must move the Queen away 27
and now I go for you for now when you
play grandmasters sometimes it's a
little scary to grab upon because they
don't like giving a pause so you think
they did it for a reason and here he
does have certain compensation but I
think that I'm holding he was 94 takes
takes Bishop h6 I'm up a pawn but he has
some idea Knight b3 he attacks my queen
I have to move it away takes takes and
he goes rogue d8 and suddenly I start
seeing what his ideas he sacrificed the
pawn h6 to start getting rid
the barrier that's between his pawn on
c4 and queening and we'll see how every
move that he makes will be targeted
towards pushing this pawn forward
I played p5 with the idea of going here
which is a very deadly threat right 94
Knight of 6 taking advantage of the
weakened dark squares it defends by
playing Bishop f5 i trade rooks defend
my pawn and he goes Knight d4 and now I
have a few choices I could move my Queen
back and try to hold and consolidate my
position or I could try to win more
material knowing which one to do is
sometimes not the easiest and this is
sometimes based purely on calculation
sometimes spade purely on intuition
sometimes it's a little bit of a
combination here it is actually wrong
for me to go back with the Queen
although that would be the natural
response of many players to move back
Queen and try to fix your position
there's just too many threats the black
house is throwing 90 - he's the a
5-pound this week the pawn pass pawn on
c4 will be a a threat and for a
grandmaster the more material the
merrier so I play Knight d5 after 95 I'm
threatening both the Queen and what
other thing I'm threatening f6 check
right so he must sacrifice bunny plays
Queen d7 and after Bishop g2 which is
forced why can I take on c4 by the way
they should take c4 it's not a good move
because ya know this right Knight f3
check if I go here for right Knight f3
check dissolves my advantage right
because now the knight comes in and my
king is very weak and this is all awful
awful things so I have to move my bishop
back and keep that Bishop on that
diagonal but he goes c3 and I go 23 and
he goes c2 and you guys remember when I
said that pawn was fast I wasn't kidding
that pawn was passed and now there is a
different kind of battle
blaka sacrificed an excessive amount of
mature sacrifice an exchange in a pawn
which is the equivalent of a piece if
you think about it right but he has a
very powerful c2 pawn and you're going
to teach you pretty much the most
important reason of why most attacks
that sacrifice do not work when you
sacrifice something you give your
opponent an opportunity to give back
part of the sacrifice material to
destroy your attack and keep the
remainder in this position it will be
foolish for me to try to keep the full
exchange what I'm going to try to do is
first neutralize that pawn and then
sacrifice back a little bit of material
so that I'm still ahead but with no
danger and this happens very often in
attacks it happens in past bonds it
happens in end games it happens in every
part of the game if you are ahead
material and you are under pressure
never be afraid to sacrifice some of
your material back
to quench that initiative in this case
the initiative only revolves around one
thing that policy - as long as I can
keep it under lock I will be able to
create my threats threats of my own
first I play at age 3 for a couple of
reasons first my light scores are very
weak second I needed our first rank left
you guys are all familiar with the left
on the first rank this is very important
for a few variations we will see in the
future and because it's the pawns
poisoned he cannot take on h3 because
after I take with my bishop the Queen
cannot recapture because of the d4
Knight being undefended he retreats the
bishop and the reason that he retreats
the bishop is to reroute it to defend
the pawn even more I play queen c3 and I
have to be very careful of not falling
for any tricks for example 92 Czech
doesn't work I can simply take it with
the rook and if the Queen comes down to
the first rank I can move my rook back
and I still hold control over the
queening square and I'm out of danger
and up a rock which is pretty nice he
goes Bishop d3 putting even more
emphasis on the pony notice how this
point is tying me down I would like to
move my rook forward I would like to
exchange some pieces I would like to
control the file none of this is
possible because of the pawn so how do
you get rid of this how do you get rid
of that pawn I play Bishop b4 at some
point first King h2 to defender one on
h3 it's not forget about that guy
hanging in some variation
I would like to attack the knight but
then we have to figure out how he goes
b5 and I go Bishop e4 the problem is
that if I do play rookie 4 I have to be
very careful of a couple of variations
the first is
am i threading roof takes d4 is this a
threat no because then you queen and
after I take on c1 he takes on d4 right
and then how's the material balance it's
it's even but it's even but let's count
it out let's say that it's white to move
and I take on d4 now to make things
simple let's say that the Queen takes on
d4 and I recapture and then he quits
what is the material balance is the same
right
wild queen he has a bishop I have a
measure me has a queen the same and what
about the pawns ah I am NOT one pawn up
I gained a second pawn how he lost it
when he Queen yeah and a common idea and
a common misconception in chess is that
when you queen you get nine points in
material and you're going to eight you
lose the pawn that you had this is very
important in some situations like this
one if I give up my rook for the night
and then he's forced the Queen by
sacrificing his own Queen I'm up two
pawns and he has no past pawn that's
excellent
that's what I was telling you guys about
giving buck material for his initiative
solicitor's the pawn my materials the
exchange and giving it back coming up
with a remainder of two extra pawns
however looking for had a serious issue
the problem was that after knight c6 as
our queen c6 there was no good would
move for me here if I traded Queens
because of the power of this night and
this pawn he was going to get the full
rook which means he was up a piece it's
just the way it works in chess and
because see how the bishop on g2 has no
influence on the Queen on c6 it kind of
gave me this possibility unfortunate
rookie for doesn't work so I have to
take it slow but in a very similar idea
I go
before he goes Bishop a4 I go queen bee
- and after queen bee - my opponent
suddenly realized what I wanted to do
he has no moves though unfortunately for
him after queen d8h for he played Queen
d7 and I went rook c1 and his rook c1
threatening the pawn if we count it out
and under every normal circumstance no
he I'm losing pieces I'm losing material
if I take on c2 but I free my position
I'm up two pawns in an endgame which is
even better and I get rid of his all his
initiative
so in essence rook c1 is done to take
that pawn in C to get rid of his
initiative and transpose into an easy to
win endgame he kind of panics in this
position of plays Bishop b3 that is part
of the beauty of the position if you
were able to defend it with the Queen I
assure you I would not have won this
game because this pawn is that powerful
however there is a certain subtlety that
I have done through the moves by putting
my bishop on e4 my pun early v my
opponent b4 there is no move from the
Queen that can defend the policy tube
and that knight on d4 at the same time
so in essence this Queen that's on d7 is
trapped defending that knight on d4 if
it were any different yes and the Queen
was able to support that point of c2 the
game would have been completely
different yes
if you put more pressure on the night
yeah but in essence that's a very
general idea what you gave me for a
tactical sequence and let's divide the
both ideas general ideas are awesome for
like strategy for pawn structures for
attacks but when you're talking about a
tactical sequence such as the rook
attacks the night and the night can
defend the bishop anymore you have to
give me a concrete answer for example
after Bishop b3 there is no way my rook
can attack the knight therefore there
it's it's relatively a moot point the
idea of bringing the bishop back was
that if he takes outside if I take on c2
immediately with the bishop he was
planning on playing Knight f3 check and
utilizing this weekend light squares to
kind of deal problems and I'm not saying
this would have necessarily worked
although it does look very pretty
dangerous but I don't have to go into
this I do it with kind of like a little
bit of patience Quincey 3 first so that
I cover f3 and remember all this ideas
of giving the material back sure he can
play 92 and fork my Queen and the rook
but then I take the bishop he takes my
rook and I take the pawn on c2 in
essence achieving what I wanted word
works what if he forced me right here
then the bishop is hanging I take and
then Quinte c2 and yes he got the
exchange back but he's still down two
pawns which is what I wanted his
initiative evaporate
so after Bishop a4 he went back I took
on c2 Bishop takes rook takes Queen d5
rook c1 and the game is relatively over
he didn't take my exchange because he
was trying to trick me a little bit but
not with so much extra material the wind
is relatively easy to play if I got
taken on c2 it would have also been
really easy to extra pawns in a queen
hand game it's pretty hopeless Queen d5
rook c1 and I'm just gonna skim through
the rest of the game he resigned in this
position now the king is completely safe
on g2 and he resigned in this position
because he's done a lot of material
notice that he said he's done exactly as
much material as he was 15 moves ago
with the huge difference that he doesn't
have his powerful policy - he doesn't
have his initiative he doesn't have his
attack so I want you guys to know that
in the first game more if he had the
idea of sacrificing a lot of material
because his opponent never had any
resources in this position the opposite
happened I had the material and I had
enough resources to get rid of his
attack so make sure that when you play
nowadays if you have extra material but
your King is on the injure if there's a
pawn queening if there are weak squares
never be afraid of giving that material
back to evaporate what is the essence of
your opponent's position and that's
pretty much all the lecture unless you
guys have any questions this is possible
to exchange for
get down to just a night versus Brooke
and try to utilize the pawns and ah even
the night versus rook at our level is
really hopeless so it's it's it's very
unlikely yeah there's just really no way
that anything would have happened so far
advanced in the game the knife with the
two pawns yeah I not only have an extra
pawn but if I can swap the Queen for the
Queen and the rook for the night that's
still winning so I mean nothing is
really going to save black from his
position that's why he resigned is an
important game if I beat him I got third
and if he beat me he got third so I mean
it was like a thousand dollar game so
it's not like he just wanted to give up
the pawn right here what are the points
sorry yeah so any other questions
I was actually the spice Cup it was held
in clay in the Sheraton hotel it was an
invitation-only tournament so there were
only about 40 players all of them at
least master level I was very strong
tournament I got a lot of publicity Rae
Robson that now lives in in st. Louis he
goes to Webster University won the
tournament rather cleanly he had a very
very good event
to you the game was further even because
he had more activity I would even say
Perl even I said here like a powerful
initiative of an attack yeah whereas in
this position even though he had the
attack my pieces were able to pretty
much neutralized everything so yeah I
think I'm a little bit over in the five
minutes over so thank you guys for the
guys